>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good morning and welcome
to the Library of Congress
and to Collections as Data.
Please welcome Kate Zwaard, Chief
of National Digital Initiatives
at the Library of Congress
[applause].
>> Kate Zwaard: Hey everybody.
Thank you so much for coming.
We're so excited you
could be here both
in person and via the live stream.
I don't have my clicker.
Is there a clicker?
>> Is it - oh, the clicker?
>> Kate Zwaard: Yeah,
I need a clicker.
Oh, it's here.
Sorry. So we're so excited
to have you here in person
and also via the live stream.
Welcome to Collections as Data.
We had an event last year you may
remember, Collections as Data,
where we discussed the challenges
and opportunities inherent
in doing computational
analysis on digital collections.
And we were really
overwhelmed by the response.
People afterwards came
up to me and talked to me
about how inspired they were,
how they thought maybe they could do
this work in their home institutions
and - but we found that we still, to
this day, are struggling to explain
in a tangible way what Collections
as Data means to our colleagues
who don't have direct experience.
So we thought we'd have this
event, Collections as Data Impact,
to invite luminaries in the
field to share their stories
about how they are providing
- about how they're using data
to better the world
and their communities.
So with that in mind, I'd like to
share with you a short story that is
from the time when computers
were people doing calculating,
not when they were
things in our pockets.
And it's my hope that this story
will connect the work you'll hear
about today to a longer history.
So this is a little bit of a
window into my high school bedroom.
You know, these beautiful
people up here [laughter].
So as you may remember the
Federalist Papers were written
by John Jay, Alexander
Hamilton, and Madison.
They were published under a
pseudonym in newspapers, Publius.
And then when changing public
opinion converted those documents
from anonymous trolling to
foundational to the democracy,
we started to get a
sense of the authorship.
And poor John Jay, only five.
So at some point the dust settled.
We knew who wrote most of
them but there were twelve
that remained in dispute.
Madison said that he didn't
have anything to do with them.
Hamilton said that
they were joint papers.
And everybody kind of figured
that it was probably Madison.
Why was there so much
finger pointing?
Well, these were propaganda pieces.
And sometimes the authors
took positions in the papers
for argument's sake
that were very different
from the ones they held publicly.
So our story really starts in
1944 when an American academic,
Douglass Adair, gathered
all the historical evidence
and determined it was
probably Madison
that wrote the disputed papers.
But he considered the
historical evidence modest,
so he sought another way
of making an analysis.
He contacted two statisticians,
Frederick Mosteller
and David Wallace, to see if
there was a computational way
of making a determination.
And I really love this quote:
"...blunder into historical
and literary controversy,
merciless slaughter is imminent."
If this story strikes
a chord with you,
I really encourage
you to read the book.
They're both just kind of
a joy to spend time with.
So they did a - they decided
to do a computational analysis
on the authorship of
the papers to see
if they could have an
independent assessment.
So they took a stack of
known Hamilton papers
and known Madison papers, and they
thought maybe calculating sentence
average would be a way
to make a determination.
So they laboriously counted in
these known papers how long each
sentence was.
And then they did some analysis.
For example, they had to
determine - they had to - sorry.
They had to determine whether
or not quoted sentences
counted toward the average.
Once they finished all this
work, they found an average
of 34.5 words per sentence
for Hamilton
and 34.6 words for
Madison [laughter].
Not going to work.
So then they decided maybe standard
deviation would be the thing.
So they did the same very
laborious counting and calculation.
They thought maybe although average
sentence length was the same,
one of the authors wrote
very average-length sentences
and the other author wrote very
teeny, tiny sentences and lots
of really long sentences.
So they did the same kind of
calculation and analysis and came
out with the same result
for both of them.
And in retrospect this
kind of makes sense.
Both authors were trained
in a similar style
that was popular during the period.
Lots of long clauses,
very kind of - I mean,
we've all read the
Federalist Papers;
you know what I'm talking
about [laughter].
So they shelved the project.
It was a year's worth of work
that didn't have any fruit.
And they kind of just
went on to other things.
A few years later, Douglas
Sidair reached back out to say
that he found something interesting.
He found that while Hamilton
uses the word "while",
Madison uses the word "whilst."
And that fact in itself is not
enough to determine authorship.
The word only occurs once
in every thousand words,
so it doesn't even appear in all the
papers - all the disputed papers.
Additionally, it could have
been introduced during the
editing process.
So it's not enough
to be a determinate.
But it gave them somewhere to start.
So they took that sample
set of known Madison papers
and known Hamilton papers and
counted the occurrence of every word
in all those sample sets.
They then correlated them
with each other to see
which words were favored by
one author versus the other.
And they scoped out
words that they called
"dangerously contextual"
which I really like.
I'm going to use that, I
don't know, later on today.
Dangerously contextual; those
were words that were correlated
with a certain author's favorite
subjects, not necessarily
with their writing style.
They came up with a total of
117 words - and this figure is
from their book - 117 words
that they could use to
make a determination.
They then used the
Bayesian analysis --
Tommy Bayes; give it up for
Tommy Bayes, everybody -
[ Applause ]
to determine - they determined
that their data made an
independent assessment
that the papers were most likely
written by Madison in the sense
of degree of belief, which I love
that because it's very
Bayesian terminology.
And what I really love
about this story is
that none of this is digital.
So this was all ink on paper.
But what does digital do for us?
It democratizes this type of work.
I mean, you could see how much
time and energy went into this.
And part - and that time and energy
was both in inventing this analysis
but also in the labor needed
to do the calculations.
And digital makes being wrong
much less expensive which is great
because I'm wrong a lot, and
I need it to be very cheap.
So to bring this talk around to
Harry Potter, which is fun to do
in any kind of academic situation,
this type of linguistic
analysis is now very common.
So a few years ago, Patrick
Juola, who's a computer scientist,
got a call from a reporter
who had a tip
that the semi-obscure mystery
writer, Robin Galbraith,
might actually be JK Rowling.
And they wanted to know if
he could do some computation
to prove that that was true.
So he ran some numbers and
he found out yes, in fact,
he could confirm the
linguistic style of JK Rowling
and Robin Galbraith
were very similar.
And so they broke the
story together.
And that brings us to today.
What I'm so excited about with
digital is that it makes this sort
of Collections as Data analysis
much more possible to more people.
I think that it brings
Collections as Data more available
to what I consider a core
constituency of the Library
of Congress which is the
informed and curious.
We're inviting a lot of
academic luminaries here today,
and we're so excited that they
could share with us their work.
We're also learning a
lot from our colleagues
in academic libraries including the
IMLS grant-funded project Always
Already Computational
Library, Collections as Data.
But a number of our speakers here
and a number of you out there are --
you know, are doing work
not connected to a large,
well-funded library;
institutional library.
And I hope that part of this
event will be to invite you
to consider the Library of
Congress an intellectual home
for exploration.
My group, National Digital
Initiatives, are really inspired
by our new boss, Dr. Carla Hayden.
She is leading us strongly
in the direction
of opening up the collections.
And we consider it part
of our job to help to do
that for the digital collections.
And with that in mind, I'd
like to share with you a few
of the things we have going on.
The first is crowdsourcing.
And so what you see here is a
screen shot of an application built
by Tong Wang who's a developer here
in the repository development
center at the library.
While he was an innovator
in residence
at NDI he had a short
- short time with us.
And it's an application built
on the Scribe platform created
by New York Public Library that
invites people to identify photos
and cartoons in historic newspapers
and to update the captions.
You can see some really
awful OCR here.
That helps us with findability.
But what's so exciting about it
to me is people engaging
with the collections.
Like, looking through historic
newspapers really getting a sense
of what's available.
And also that we can
create these data sets.
So we can create maybe a gallery
of World War I-era cartoons
that I think is really
useful for scholarship
and interesting to page through.
This is not the only crowdsourcing
project we're working on,
but I'll save those
details for another time.
And it's our hope that this will
blend into a portfolio of projects
that the Library of Congress is
working on that helps us engage with
and learn from our users including
Flickr, the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting game,
and efforts in the Law Library
and the World Digital Library.
Bud Barton, our CIO,
announced recently
that we'll be doing a
congressional data challenge.
He announced this at the Legislative
Data and Transparency Conference.
We'd like to invite people to
play with congressional data
and find ways to make
our democracy, you know,
even more robust using the
information we're making available.
We're working on the details,
and we hope to have something
to announce about that soon.
I am thrilled to give you guys a
sneak peek into what we're launching
in a few months, and
that's labs.loc.gov.
I'm really excited about this.
It's going to be a platform
for play and discovery
with the digital collections.
It's my hope that this will
reduce the friction to innovation,
and we'll be able to use
it also as a home for NDI.
So it'll make our work a
little bit more easy to follow
and provide us a place to host the
results of innovators and residents
and challenge grants and
information about our hackathons.
This one's pictured here.
I love this picture because
when you watch movies
about people writing code
it's all, like, head down,
dak-a-dak-a-dak-a-dak-a-dak-a.
But when I write code it's mostly me
staring at a screen trying to figure
out why it's doing that
[laughter], pictured here.
So while I have you trapped here -
because we've got some amazing
speakers so I know you're not going
to leave - I'd like to selfishly
go through a few things.
The first is jobs.
There are some really cool
jobs posted right now,
and I have a feeling there'll
be more really cool jobs posted
in the near future.
So please check this out.
We need your good brains
to come here.
So if you find jobs that, like,
your friend might be good for,
please send it and
check back very often.
The second, the Kluge
Fellowship in Digital Studies.
So if you don't want to come here
for a lifetime, which you should;
but if you don't want to, you
can come here for just a visit.
These are paid fellowships to
bring people into the library
to study the digital revolution on
society using library collections.
And if you come here and do one of
these, I will hang out with you.
I will. But don't not
- don't not apply
because you're worried
about that [laugher].
Like, I'll just call you;
and if you don't want
to do that, you don't have to.
But it's really fun, and we'll have
two Kluge scholars presenting the
lightening round.
So if you're inspired by their
work, please come and apply.
They can award more than one a
year, so share it with your friends.
Don't horde it.
You can send it out to people.
The third is Innovators
in Residence.
So we've been working hard on an
Innovators in Residence program here
to bring people into the
library for short-term,
high-impact technical projects.
Sorry. And the idea behind this
is to bring some fresh ideas,
new blood, great brains to create
new access points to the collection.
Innovators in Residence projects
have included the crowdsourcing
project that I referenced earlier, a
MARC parser to help people interact
with the bibliographic
records the Library
of Congress recently released,
and we'll have more information
about this year's soon.
So thanks for coming.
I'm so thrilled you're here.
As I mentioned when we launch
blogs.loc.gov it'll be much easier
to follow what we're working on.
In the meantime, please
check the blog.
You can sign up for e-mail alerts.
We won't have time
for questions today.
It's wall-to-wall information
into your brains.
But we're encouraging
you to please interact
with the speakers directly
on social media.
You can also comment on the
blog with any questions.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.